i've spoken a lot about second order
linear homogeneous differential
equations in abstract terms and how if
you know g is a solution then some
constant times g is also solution or if
g and h are solutions then g plus h is
also solution let's actually do problems
because i think that will actually help
you learn as opposed to help you get
confused so let's say i have this
differential equation
y the second
derivative of y with respect to x
plus
5
times
the first derivative of y with respect
to x
plus
six times y
is equal to zero
so we need to find a y where you know
one times its second derivative plus
five times its first derivative plus six
times itself is equal to zero and now
let's let's just do a little bit of
to take a step back and think about what
kind of function you know most functions
when i take if i have the function i
take its derivative and then i take its
second derivative most times i get
something completely different right
like if i have if i have you know if y
was i don't know if y was um if y was
i'm just trying to think of if y was x
squared then y prime would be
2x then y prime prime would be 2. and
then to add them together you'd say well
how would my x terms cancel out i don't
you know it so that you get 0 in the end
so you know draw back into your brain
and think is there some function
that
you know when i take its first and
second derivatives and third and fourth
derivatives it essentially becomes this
becomes the same function maybe the the
the multiple time
is the constant in front of the function
changes as i take the derivative
and if if you've listened to a lot of my
videos you'd realize that it probably is
what i consider to be the most amazing
function in mathematics and that is
the function e to the x
and in particular you know maybe e to
the x won't work here you could even try
it out right if you did e to the x it
won't satisfy this this equation right e
to the x would you know you'd get e to
the x plus 5 e to the x plus 60 x that
would not equal to zero but maybe it's
maybe y
maybe y is equal to
e to some constant r
times x
let's just make the assumption that y is
equal to some constant r times x
substitute it back into this and then
see if we can actually solve for an r
that makes this equation true and if we
can we've we've found the solution or
maybe we found several solutions so
let's try it out let's let's try y is
equal to e to the rx into this
differential equation so what is the
first derivative of it first of all it's
always useful too
so y prime is equal to what derivative
chain rule derivative of the inside is
r
and then derivative of the outside is
still just e to the rx
and what's the second derivative
y prime prime is equal to
derivative r is just a constant so the
derivative of the inside is r times r on
the outside that's r squared
times e to the rx
and now we're ready to substitute back
in so and i will switch
colors so y the second derivative that's
r squared
times e to the rx
plus five times the first derivative so
that's five
r
e to the r
x
plus six times our function
six times e to the r
x is equal to zero
and something might already be surfacing
to you as something we can do to this
equation to solve for r
all of these terms on the left all have
an e to the rx so let's let's let's
factor that out
so this is equal to
e
to the rx
times r squared plus let's see 5
r
plus
6
is equal to
0.
and our goal remember was to solve for
the r or the rs that will make this true
in order for this side of the equation
to be zero what do we know can can e to
the rx ever equal zero can you ever get
something to some exponent and and get
zero well we'll know so this cannot
equal zero so in order for this
left-hand side of the equation to be
zero
this term this expression right here has
to be zero
and i'll do that in a different color
so we know if we want to solve for r
that this
r squared plus five r plus six
that has to be zero
and this
this is called the characteristic
equation this or this the r squared plus
five r plus six is called the
characteristic equation
and it should be obvious to you that now
this is no longer calculus this is
this is just factoring a quadratic and
this one actually is fairly
straightforward to factor so what is
this this is
r plus
2
times
r plus 3
is equal to 0.
and so the solutions of the
characteristic equation are actually the
solutions to this original equation are
r is equal to negative 2
r is equal to negative 2 and
r
is equal to
minus 3.
so you say hey we found two solutions
because we found two suitable r's that
make this equation true this
differential equation true and what are
those well the first one is y is equal
to e to the
minus two x right r is minus two and
then we could call that y1
and then the second solution we found y2
is
e
to the
what is this r is minus 3x
now my question to you is are these is
this the most general solution well in
the last video in kind of our
introductory video we learned that a
constant times a solution is still a
solution
so if y1 is a solution we also know that
we can multiply y1 times any constant so
let's do that let's multiply it by c1
that's a c1 there this is also going to
be a solution now it's a little bit more
general right it's a whole class of
functions it's the c doesn't have to
just be a one it can be any constant and
we'll and then when you use your initial
values you actually can figure out what
that constant is and same for y2 y2 it
doesn't have to be 1 times e to the
minus 3x it has to be some any constant
and we learned that in the last video
that if something's a solution some
constant times that is also a solution
and we also learned that if we have two
different solutions that if you add them
together you also get a solution so the
the most general solution to this
differential equation is
y
we could say y of x just to
hit it home that this is definitely a
function of x
y of x is equal to c 1
e to the minus 2 x
plus
c2
e to the minus 3x
and this is the general solution of this
differential equation and i won't prove
it because the proof is fairly involved
i mean we just tried out e to the rx
maybe there's some other wacko function
that would have worked here but i'll
tell you now and you kind of have to
take it as a leap of faith
that this is the only general solution
there isn't some crazy
outside function there that would have
also worked and so the other question
that might be popping in your brain
is sal
in previous when we did first order
differential equations we only had one
constant and that was okay because we we
had one set of initial conditions and we
solved for our constants but here i have
two constants so if i wanted a
particular solution how can i solve for
two variables if i'm only given one
initial condition and if that's what you
actually thought your intuition would be
correct you actually need two initial
conditions to solve this
differential equation you would need to
know what you know at a given at a given
value of x what y is equal to and maybe
at a given value of x what the first
derivative is
and that is what we will do in the next
video see you soon